[Music]
welcome back
so in the last lecture we derived the
potential flow vector field v
which is the
gradient of a scalar potential phi that
satisfies laplace's equation
so in some sense we actually derived
laplace's equation as the partial
differential equation needed to find a
suitable potential function fee so that
if you take its gradient you get a
vector field that is steady
incompressible and irrotational so it
doesn't change in time it has no
divergence and it has no curl everywhere
in space and so today we're going to
zoom in a little bit more and look at
what are some of the properties of these
potential flows
and what are some of the properties of
laplace's equation so this is one of the
most fundamental pdes in all of physics
and the resulting potential flow can be
used to describe a lot of phenomena in
fluid flow physics
okay so i'm going to jump right in
and then i'm also going to give a couple
of examples we're actually going to use
this complex potential function
to derive some potential flows
so the first thing i want to
to do is essentially just
describe some of the properties of what
happens in one of these potential flows
so imagine that i have a fluid flow
vector field and we're going to call
this
v you know our vector field
some
some unsteady flow field v
and imagine that we have some closed
curve c this is just an orbit that we
kind of make up this is kind of like a
control volume that we're we're putting
you know we're just placing this in the
flow and we're saying what happens
inside and outside and on the boundary
of this curve
uh we'll call this curve
c good
and then one last thing i'll do to set
up this problem is at every point we're
going to establish a tangent and a
normal vector
so we're going to say that the normal
vector is
n bar and the tangent vector is a little
uh a little u
bar
good
now
a potential flow a vector field v that
is steady incompressible and
irrotational
i.e that is the gradient of a potential
solution of laplace's equation
has two really important properties on
any closed curve c uh in two dimension
the first property
is
that if i take a contour integral around
c
of my vector field v
dotted in this kind of tangential u
direction
uh integrated across you know every
little segment of this of this contour
so i'm literally taking my vector field
and i'm seeing how much component of it
is in this uh
this tangential direction u and i
integrate that around the contour
we know that this is going to be equal
to zero because of stokes's theorem so
by stokes's theorem
this says
that we have uh this contour integral
is equal to a surface integral inside of
c so kind of a surface integral inside
c
of the curl
of my vector field v
times every little area element
and again because we know that this is
an irrotational flow by construction
this curl is 0 everywhere
and what this tells us
is that
if i take my velocity component of my
velocity field dot it into the u
direction and i integrate it around any
closed curve c it has to equal zero
what that means is that there is zero
net circulation there is
zero
net circulation
or vorticity
around
c
and that's for all closed curve c
so this is one really really useful
property
of potential flows
similarly we can write down a similar
property of the divergence
of the vector field so let's write that
one down i'll do this one in orange
and so what we have here
is that the contour integral around c
of v
dotted now into the normal direction
again integrated on every little segment
around this contour so we're again
integrating around this contour but now
we're taking the component of v that's
pointing normal uh to the to the contour
and when we integrate that around
we find similarly by gauss's divergence
theorem
that
now we similarly have a volume integral
inside
c
of the divergence of v
times every little area element and
again by construction we know that this
is an incompressible field and so the
divergence is zero everywhere
and so we know that there is no net
component of v integrated on the surface
and this was that flux integral that we
had been looking at before where we
integrated kind of the the component of
v that's carrying you out through the
normal direction of the surface
integrated on the whole surface
of the flow field so this essentially is
a statement that there is zero net flux
through the contour
so this is a zero
zero net flux
across c
okay so these are two extremely useful
properties
now you might think that this is a
little bit different than the
formulation of gauss's divergence
theorem i derived a few lectures ago
where in that case this was a surface
integral and this was a volume integral
but the same exact idea applies in two
dimensions now where the flux
is the integral of my vector field in
the normal direction around some closed
contour
and kind of the
sum of all the divergences inside is now
a a surface integral so this is still
gauss's diversion divergence theorem
this is still
stokes's or green's theorem in 2d
and so essentially by construction our
potential flow has these very very nice
properties that around any closed
contour you can draw in your flow field
again imagine this is like the gulf of
mexico
flow and you pick any closed loop uh you
like there will be zero net circulation
around c and zero net mass flux across c
if you have a potential flow solution if
the fluid flow is truly a potential flow
that satisfies these conditions here
so i think that's really really neat
okay now what i want to do is actually
give you some examples of a potential
flow and show you kind of draw the
vector field analyze the potential flow
show that it's incompressible and
irrotational
for some of these complex potentials
okay
so we've talked about what potential
flow is how it relates to laplace's
equation
and in the last lecture i showed you
that if you have an analytic complex
function phi of z this could be
something like z squared z to the third
z to the fourth cosine z sine z e to the
z
in terms of some complex variable x plus
i y
where i is the square root of negative
one the imaginary number
then for any of these analytic complex
functions
if you look at the real part and the
imaginary part of those functions
they have to satisfy something called
the koshi riemann conditions for this to
be analytic
and those koshi riemann conditions
essentially guarantee that the the real
part fee
and the imaginary part psi
are both solutions of laplace's equation
these are both uh kind of these these
harmonic functions that satisfy
laplace's equation and these can be used
as potentials uh
this is the can be used as a potential
for potential flows
so any analytic function if you take its
real part and then you take the gradient
of that function that will give you a
potential flow guaranteed and this is a
cornerstone result in complex analysis
one of the most important results in
complex number theory and that's
probably why most you know a lot of
departments still have complex analysis
in part of their core engineering math
sequence even though it might seem kind
of esoteric
it can be really useful to find
solutions of laplace's equation one of
the most useful uh
reasons we study complex analysis
okay so we're actually going to do this
for
z squared
and maybe before i do that i will point
out
uh here
that our flow v
v1 and v2 which is the gradient of phi
i'm just going to write this out
as
partial phi partial x
and partial phi partial y that is what
that vector field equals okay that is my
potential flow vector field
and i'll also point out
you can get the exact same these uh
functions phi and psi have a they're
related to each other they're not
completely independent because they're
the real and imaginary part of an
analytic function z
and so this vector field can also be
derived through the stream function
as partial
psi partial y
and minus partial psi
partial x
now this is just
you know usually i work with the
potential function i am more comfortable
with this a lot of people work with the
stream function in fluid mechanics this
is a very common representation of fluid
flows and fluid mechanics
because essentially level sets of psi
actually give you these streamlines the
stream function is constant along
streamlines of the flow so that's a very
very useful
quantity
and really really interesting this
actually has the same structure
as the hamiltonian equations of motion
hamilton's equations
and so in some cases you can think of
the stream function psi as a hamiltonian
energy function
that's just kind of a neat connection uh
that
that that you can draw from so i'm just
going to say sometimes this is a
hamiltonian
okay good
so we're going to derive this for z
squared and we're going to actually draw
the phase portrait and look at
properties of this this vector field
here
so let's actually do that and maybe i
will do that in
blue
so z squared if i have z equals x plus y
so let's just do this
z squared equals x plus i y
squared
equals okay i'm going to collect all of
my real parts and my imaginary parts so
i would have x squared
x squared plus i squared y squared which
is minus y squared those are the two
real parts
and then i'll have plus 2
i x y
and what i'm actually going to do
i'm going to move my imaginary
out front so i can keep track of it a
little bit better
so this is plus
i
2xy
okay good
this is my potential function fee this
is literally
my potential function
and this
is my stream function
good
and so now what we're going to do is
this z squared this potential function
phi or this stream function psi
actually establishes a vector field v so
that's that's what we're going to do so
we're going to say that v
equals
partial phi partial x so partial phi
partial x is just 2x
and partial phi partial y
is minus 2 y
now you can verify that you can also get
it from the stream function if i take
partial psi partial y i have 2x
and if i take minus partial psi partial
x i have minus 2y so you can get this
vector field either from the potential
flow
or from the stream function those both
work
and so this is actually my my vector
field
so the first thing we can do is verify
that it's incompressible
and irrotational so that's pretty easy
to do if you um
i mean let's just do it right so if i
look at uh the
divergence of v
it'll be partial of the first term with
respect to x plus partial of the second
term with respect to y
which is 2 minus 2 equals 0 check
similarly we can check that this is in
irrotational so we look at the curl of v
and the curl of v is partial the first
one with respect to y minus partial the
second one with respect to x the first
term doesn't have a function of y and
this is not a function of x so those are
both zero so zero plus zero equals zero
check
so this is incompressible and
irrotational good
and you could also verify that both of
these functions satisfy laplace's
equation let's do that i think i'm just
going through the motions of confirming
for you that if you have an analytic
function
and you expand it out in complex
variables the real and imaginary parts
are solutions of laplace's equation and
can give you an incompressible
irrotational vector field
so um just writing this down what we
have is we're going to confirm that the
fee function satisfies laplace's
equation
which literally means
partial squared phi partial
x squared
plus partial squared phi
partial y squared apology my fees look
terrible those are that's a
5 function
so if i take
this function and its second derivative
with respect to x the first derivative
is 2x the next derivative is 2.
if i take the same function the second
derivative with respect to y is minus
two
and again that equals zero this function
uh satisfies laplace's equation it
satisfies the the second partial
derivative sum equals zero
we'll check the stream function
satisfies laplace's equation so same
thing partial
squared psi
partial x squared
plus partial squared psi partial y
squared
equals
now this function if i take its
derivative with respect to x once i get
2y and if i take its second derivative
with respect to x it gets 0 because 2y
is not a function of x
so this thing you know the second
derivative of x or y is equal to 0. so
again 0 plus 0 equals 0 check
so what we've done here is we have taken
an analytic function z squared
we've expanded it in the complex
variables and collected the real and the
imaginary parts
and those real parts and imaginary parts
are functions of x and y
and those functions satisfy laplace's
equation the potential function and the
stream function satisfy laplace's
equation
and so if i take the gradient of phi i
get a vector field that is
incompressible and irrotational that's
really really useful
now i'm actually going to draw this
vector field for you because it looks
cool
and i think it will help kind of give
you an idea of what
what's actually happening here
so what we're going to do is we're going
to draw this
this vector field
and this vector field is 2x and minus 2y
which means that
any point if i am in just the x
direction if i'm at x equals 1 y equals
0 then this vector is 2 0.
so it kind of is pointing in that
direction and the farther out i get the
faster this arrow goes
and in the negative direction the arrows
are pointing in the negative direction
but if i go in the y direction if i take
a unit step in the y direction my vector
field is 0 minus 2. so it's actually
pointing in
and the farther i go the faster it
points in as you would expect
and so this is how my vector field looks
and if i go a little bit to the left
like at this point 1 1
then i have a vector that's moving to
the right 2 and down
2 and so it will look kind of like this
and i hope i'm actually drawing this
right i think i am
what this ends up looking like is kind
of like a saddle function
um
so this this looks like a saddle things
are smooshing down in the y direction
and stretching out in the x direction
and so this function this vector field
is in fact incompressible and
irrotational so if i take a little blob
of
mass like let's say i take a little
blob of goop here
and i flow it along this vector field i
like i drop some oil in this vector
field and i flow it along
it will stretch out in the x direction
it will get bigger in the x direction
but it gets compressed as much in the y
direction so it ends up getting
stretched out
in the y direction in the x direction as
it gets smooshed in the y direction
and so the total area of this blob is
constant as you flow through that is
what we mean by
divergence being zero all
closed areas are preserved as you flow
it through through this field
and siri similarly because this is
irrotational this blob doesn't rotate or
kind of shear or distort as it as it
flows it just it just stretches out but
it doesn't actually go through this
solid body rotation so the orientation
of this object remains conserved
uh through this flow
now one of the last things i want to
show you and i think this is really
important so let's let's slow down i
want you to really listen this is one of
the most important uh kind of ideas in
vector calculus in in this whole vector
calculus and partial differential
equations
is that when we have a pde
the solution of that pde often defines a
vector field
and then i can take that vector field
and i can imagine that i am a particle
in that vector field i can imagine that
i am some particle x and y
so that
ddt
of x and y
equals v1 of x and y
v2 of x
and y
and so essentially what we get is a
differential equation this this vector
field can be thought of as an ordinary
differential equation for how a particle
moves
through
this uh this fluid flow so i want to say
this again it's kind of a three-step
process i have a partial differential
equation so i have
one i have a pde
two that gives me a vector field
a vector field v
and then finally three
we think about a particle the ode this
vector field v is an ordinary
differential equation
for a particle
in the vector field
and this is a really really important
concept
that oftentimes for example the navy or
stokes equation is a partial
differential equation
the solution of the navier-stokes
equation is a vector field v
it's not steady and compressible
incompressible and irrotational it is
unsteady and has you know can be
compressible and rotating but it's a
vector field v
and then i can think about particles in
that vector field and i can drop
particles in that vector field and
integrate them along and so that's kind
of a three-step process we use to think
about um
partial differential equations vector
calculus and uh and and flows in general
and so we're actually going to integrate
particles through the navy or stokes
vector field which is the solution of
the navier-stokes equation that's one of
the most useful tools we have
for visualizing fluid flows is
integrating particles and seeing where
they go you know in smoke visualizations
in old wind tunnels you'd put a
cigarette or a piece of incense in the
wind tunnel and you'd see where those
particles collect
and that tells you a lot about the the
structure of that flow looking at where
particles collect
when we unfortunately or accidentally
drop pollution in the ocean we can see
where it goes or we can predict where it
goes by integrating those particles
through the navier-stokes vector field
which is the solution of a partial
differential equation
very useful stuff
and you can picture that here so in this
case i said that this looks like a
saddle it doesn't just look like a
saddle it is a saddle so if i take
this vector field here i have x dot and
y dot
equal
2x and minus 2y
and if you like you can write this in
our normal ordinary differential
equation form as a matrix
2 0 0 minus 2
times the state vector x and y
and so now you see that this is in fact
exactly a saddle point this
is a there's a fixed point at the origin
of this differential equation this is a
linear ode
it has a fixed point at the origin and
it has an eigenvalue of plus 2 in the x
direction and minus 2 in the y direction
if i looked at the eigenvectors the plus
2 eigenvalue would have an eigenvector
in the x direction
the minus 2 eigenvalue would have an
eigenvector in the y direction
and so this
this potential function here
which satisfies laplace's equation
gives me a potential flow vector field v
where if i drop a particle in that
potential flow it behaves according to
this linear saddle point ordinary
differential equation my particles
literally are going to do
what i expect my saddle points uh
dynamics to do
okay so this is what would happen if i
integrated a particle along that vector
field
and that's a really really useful
perspective so we're going to
in the future we're actually going to
use this to study
more complicated fluid flows like the
ocean gyres is a really common vector
field that you can model as a potential
flow so if you look at
ocean flows often there's two big
counter rotating basins that have big
circulation
and occasionally over seasons they kind
of drift and breathe
and even that very simple model of two
counter roading
rotating vortices that breathe can give
you chaotic mixing in the ocean it's a
really cool model system
and it can be modeled it turns out using
one of these potential flows
so i can essentially build a potential
flow in a box
that has these two big counter rotating
vortices so this one moves in this
direction this one moves in this
direction
i hope i can draw this it's a little
tricky to get just right
okay this one's going this way i guess
this one's going
this way
and so on and so forth okay so this is
just a big counter rotating uh set of
vortices
and it turns out that there is an
approximate potential flow solution that
gives you this kind of counter rotating
ocean gyre and you can modify it to make
these slosh back and forth
and that potential function actually i'm
going to do it with a stream function
that stream function is just
psi
of x and y
equals sine pi x
times sine pi y
and you can verify that that vector
field uh that you get out by by taking
this uh partial derivative here
satisfies this uh this this vector field
so v
uh equals you know partial psi partial y
and minus partial psi partial x
and it turns out that that equals a
vector field given by pi
uh sine pi x
times cos pi y
and another the y component of this
vector field is minus pi
uh cos pi x
times sine
pi y
and if you actually uh in matlab or in
python start plotting kind of the the
streamlines the level sets or you start
plotting this vector field established
here
you'll see that this actually creates
this counter rotating ocean gyre and so
this is something i often with my class
will code up and we'll start dropping
particles we'll see where they start
stretching and mixing and we'll actually
you know compute these quantities and
compute uh you know drop a blob of
particles and see how they stretch and
fold
okay so big picture summary potential
flow is a really really useful subset of
vector fields that are steady
incompressible and irrotational
they are obtained by taking the gradient
of a potential function that satisfies
laplace's equation or taking this kind
of skew gradient of the corresponding
stream function for complex potentials
and it turns out that any analytic
complex function z squared z cubed z to
the fourth any polynomial in z
cosine of z sine of z e to the z
log of z away from the origin will
establish these analytic functions these
these uh harmonic real part and
imaginary part that are solutions of
laplace's equation and so these will
give you potential or stream functions
that can be used to derive these vector
fields
so this gives you an entire infinite
family of vector fields that satisfies
these properties from these simple
complex functions
really really useful and in fact these
are the building blocks that that for
decades people use to design aircraft
wings so if you want to design a wing so
that you get the right flow
kind of over the wing
and it has the right lift and drag
properties that you want
you can essentially
create these potential flows using these
analytic functions as building blocks to
kind of build up the features of the
flow and the wing that you want for
design that's what people did before
computers and it's pretty remarkable all
right thank you